[Music]
okay so now we're going to code this up
and I'm gonna code this up in Python
good and so here we're basically going
to just recreate this example we're
gonna have a bunch of data points with a
true slope that we know we're gonna
introduce an outlier and we're gonna see
how l1 and l2 compare okay so we're
gonna create a bunch of X points at
random and then I'm gonna sort them so I
can have them ordered from small to big
you don't really have to do that I just
like doing that and then B is gonna be
0.9 times X plus some random noise and
so that means that my a my true a value
here is 0.9 that's the actual slope of
my system so I'm just gonna run this get
this running okay and I'm gonna add all
of that white noise so ads might noise
but I'm going to introduce one massive
outlier at the end here this this last
points gonna be a big outlier now I
should point out if I didn't have this
outlier if I if I didn't have that
outlier these scores would actually do a
pretty good job if I just had white
noise on top of my data that would at
least scores actually does a great job
of estimating the slope if I just had
white noise it's only when I introduce
that outlier that it's gonna really
break my least square solution and
require me to do something different
okay good so here we have the least
square solution is really easy to
compute using this least squares it's
really simple right it's a one-line
built in tune them pies linear algebra
package and so here we're estimating the
slope a but on the noisy data that has
this outlier so I don't think it's gonna
do a very good job and then I'm gonna
plot this for you did I run this good I
think I did so now I'm gonna plot this
for you and what you see here is that in
blue we have the actual data and the
blue dashed the blue dashed is the true
the true model this is with slope point
9 and then we have this single bad
outlier here that's really really bad so
I'm using this to kind of as a cartoon
to illustrate how bad things can be but
that's single bad
we'll tilt my entire distribution down
because remember I'm trying to minimize
the square error here and the square
error to this outlier is so massive that
the whole distribution it's willing to
have this much error with every other
data point to make it a little bit
smaller error with that red outlier and
so a single outlier can ruin your least
squares regression I mean absolutely
ruin the least squares fit it's a big
problem and so either you'd have to
painstakingly go throughout your data
and try to remove all of those outliers
by hand which could be really subjective
and really time-consuming or we can
introduce this one norm and try to fix
it kind of automatically okay so that's
what we're gonna do now so now we're
gonna minimize with the one norm so
again we define the one norm we're using
kind of this built-in minimization line
or command so I'm gonna run this and get
ran and now I'm going to plot beautiful
ok so now when I minimize the one norm
of the error instead of the two nor of
the error you see this white curve is
our l1 fit and it is almost perfectly on
top of the true model ok so the and this
is because we're not squaring our error
okay so we're not squaring our errors
and so it has is strongly incentivized
to stay kind of pinned to the true data
points because if it moved away it
wouldn't you know it wouldn't help it in
this in this one norm error okay so this
is really cool the one norm adds a
tremendous amount of robustness to
outliers okay in the real world real
data is dirty your sensors are gonna
fail sometimes people are going to write
down the wrong values you get fat finger
data entries all the time and when you
deal with real-world data you are gonna
have outliers and corruption and missing
values and all kinds of problems the l1
norm gives you an incredible robustness
when you're doing data fitting this is
just this is a crude really really
simple model you could call this
artificial intelligence or machine
learning if you want this is a linear
regression okay
a lot of machine learning is regression
and linear regression and you're gonna
get the wrong answer if you have
outliers and you're using least squares
fitting so you have to back up and think
to yourself if you're using if you have
outliers if you have corrupt data you
might want to think about adding L 1
error penalties instead of L 2 error
penalties okay so this is kind of the
first we've seen about how the L 1 can
also be very robust to fiying and we're
going to explore that more in future
videos ok thanks and see you next time